DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Hi, Martin.
I'm working on a design doc.
Do you have a few minutes
to help me with it?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
I love design sessions.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Great.
OK.
We have these on-prem servers
and our new developers
keep building new things, which
is great, but I'm thinking I
need some kind of
web application
to help me manage it
all, that and some batch
processing to keep track
of the state of things.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
This new application sounds like
a good use case for serverless.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
High level, we
want to make sure they go
through the proper approval
process before
launching a new service,
and frankly, it's
getting difficult to keep
track of everything.
I want to build an
application that
helps me manage open
ports on the servers,
keeps a log for our auditors,
and allows developers
to easily file
requests for opening up
access for new applications.
We have three distinct users.
We have a developer, an
admin, and an auditor,
and the developer should
be able to make requests
for new open ports
through a web application,
and the admin should be able
to approve those requests.
The admin should
also get notified
if there are ever any open
ports that he did not approve.
And then the auditor
should be able to see
just the entire logs
of all the things that
have been opened at any time.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, cool.
Sounds good.
So we have them here.
We started our system diagram,
and down in the lower right
hand corner, we put the servers
that they're monitoring.
This is a company internal app.
Is that right?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yeah,
it's completely internal.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, got it.
So they are employees.
They should be able to reach
it, but no other external users
should be able to
reach this application?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: What
might we put in there
to make it easy to keep
employees in and everybody
else out?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: I think
another thing to consider
is, first of all, it's
only internal employees,
but also, these two employees
have different permissions
of different roles of the
things that they can do.
So it should be something that
allows us to kind of tweak
and tune the permissions levels.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
that's a good point.
Developers and admins can
do different things, yeah.
So I'm thinking,
then, identity aware
proxy here backed by App Engine.
It's really easy to put IAP
and App Engine together.
Do you think that
would work here?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yeah.
No, I think that
would work great.
OK, so then App Engine with
a little IAP in front of it,
controls, like, who can get in.
OK, so now we need to think
about storage because they
are going to be making requests
and approving requests,
so that means that we need to
be able to create, read, update,
delete some kind of something.
And to me, the big question
is, do we use NoSQL or SQL?
MARTIN OMANDER: So we're trying
to keep it serverless, which
would mean NoSQL,
and I'm also thinking
there won't be too
many reports of-- we
won't do too many aggregations,
like averages, and sums,
and stuff like that, right?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
I think just
thinking about how the people
are interacting with the data
and also how I would
model the data,
NoSQL is really feeling
like the right direction
because they're not going
to have to do big reports.
And even when you think
about, like, we have a server,
the server is represented
by the IP address
and then we have a set
of ports underneath it.
So if I were to have a
document in a NoSQL database,
the document, the ID
would be the IP address,
and then we'd have the list of
ports in it as rows and then
whether or not it
should be open.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, yeah.
It's kind of hierarchical
like that, yeah.
I agree.
So yeah, let's go for NoSQL.
Firestore is great
and serverless,
so it would go
very well together
with the other serverless
components here.
Each document, I guess,
would be a server.
And as you said, underneath
it has ports, and permissions,
and things.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
For our auditor
and also for just
our peace of mind,
we want to write a little port
scanner so that we can check,
we can check that all
the ports that are open
are the ones that
have been approved,
and I want this
to happen nightly,
and I don't want
any interaction.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, so nobody
goes in and clicks and says,
scan the ports right now.
OK, got it.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Yeah, like a cron job.
But I don't want the
cron job on my computer.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And Dina closes her laptop
and goes on vacation
and no cron jobs are running.
Yeah, so right.
And, of course, the way to
run cron jobs in Google Cloud
platform is Cloud Scheduler.
I think that would be
a great choice here.
We can set it to run nightly,
or change it to run hourly,
or whatever.
And then the Cloud Scheduler
would need to call something.
What kind of component
should it call, I wonder?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: So
thinking of the functionality
that we want, what
we want to do is
we want to have the
IP address and we
want to attempt
to make a request
to connect to every single
port on the IP address.
So we're thinking about,
like, nested for loops, which
actually sounds really scary.
Oh my gosh.
But the first thing
that we need to do
is we need to get the
list of IP addresses.
So maybe we can break up this
functionality a little bit
and have the first function
just call to Firestore
and get that list of IP address.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
I really like that.
Yeah, so OK, so that first
function is really simple.
Like you said, it just
gets all the records
and does no port
scanning on itself, OK.
So no nested for loop
here, but that one
is just pulling out the data.
Now, who does the actual work?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: That
is a really great question
because I don't
want to just call
another function
because then we have
the problem of the
nested for loops.
And if you're going through
the tens of thousands
of maybe millions
of ports, like,
something's going
to break, and it's
going to take a really
long time, and then
what are you going to do,
just restart the whole thing?
So--
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
Right.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
I'd really like
to do some kind of asynchronous,
fan out, kind of something--
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
you said asynchronous.
When you say asynchronous, Dina,
that makes me think of Pub/Sub.
So would it work if the
orchestration function
published one Pub/Sub
message for every server
and then we had those messages
trigger different Cloud
Function that tested
just one server each?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
That is so good.
That's, like, even better
than what I was originally
thinking because what
that allows us to do,
then, is if our function
fails for some reason, right,
then we only have to retry that
one port on that one server
and we don't have to worry
about the hundreds of thousands
or millions of other ports.
It's just the one.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, right?
So it doesn't get
stuck, no time outs.
OK.
This is really good.
So the port tester, then,
gets just one server
that did your test or maybe
one server and one port
combination.
It tests that, so it's a
really simple function.
Now, it needs to put
the data somewhere,
and I'm especially
looking over there
to the left at
where it says Admin.
The admin should get an
email whenever a port is open
that shouldn't be open, right?
How do we get that data
over there into that email?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Right.
So I think, then,
what we need is
when we get to this port
tester Cloud Function,
we're feeding in the
IP address, the port,
and whether or not
it should be open,
and then we're receiving
back the response of,
like, true or
false, it was open.
And so then we want all of
these four pieces of data to--
especially if it doesn't
match, like, if it's open
and it shouldn't be
open or if it's not open
and it should be open,
because that can happen too,
then we want that
to trigger an email.
But also, we want
everything, not just
the things that don't
match, we want everything
to go to the auditor.
And so I think maybe we're going
to do, like, another Pub/Sub
thing.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, right.
Because-- and I think the
reason that this fits very well
is when you said this
data goes to two places,
Pub/Sub is amazing
for that, right?
You publish it once and then you
can have multiple subscribers.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yes.
Yes, multiple
subscribers, and we
can do a filtered subscription
so then our little function
doesn't have to do any logic.
It doesn't have to say,
like, hey, if else,
just go here, go here.
We're just sending
everything to Pub/Sub
and then we can have our
filtered subscription that
will pick up whenever the match
thing doesn't happen, you know?
And that can trigger an email.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Oh, right, right.
Yep, yep.
So we have that
filter subscription
could go into App Engine.
App Engine has that little
logic, little handler in there,
that whenever it gets
one of these messages,
it does what you just described.
It calls an email,
API sends an email.
Cool.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: I love it.
MARTIN OMANDER: So we have
that dangling thing down there.
The auditor looks a little
lonely in the lower left hand
corner.
How do we get data to them?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Right.
OK, so let's work
backwards a little bit.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
The auditor is
going to want to
look at a report,
maybe, like, in a dashboard.
And when I think
about dashboards,
I start thinking about SQL.
Like, you want to be
able to write queries.
So we should be
storing this data
in something that has kind
of like a SQL interface.
And I'm thinking because we're
just, like, appending rows,
and it's going to
be a lot of data,
I'm thinking BigQuery
might be a good option.
MARTIN OMANDER: I
really like that, yeah.
Yeah, because this is exactly
what BigQuery is for, right?
Reporting.
And yeah, so we just put a
little Cloud Function in there
that is triggered.
So I guess this one would not
be a filtered subscription.
It would be a regular
old subscription, right?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, everything.
We want everything.
The auditor wants to see it all.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
All right.
Very nice.
So now we have auditor
wants a web page,
the data is in BigQuery already.
This is great.
Now-- but we need that
web page and BigQuery
to meet here somewhere.
I mean, should we sit
down and write the web app
and figure out some library
that can draw graphs and things?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Oh, god.
No, I don't want to do that.
MARTIN OMANDER: I've done
it on so many projects,
I really don't want
to do it either, yes.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: OK.
I'm going to throw
this out there.
I think we should use Data
Studio because when you're
looking at BigQuery,
there's already
a button that's like, hey, look
at this data in Data Studio,
so there we go.
Easy .
MARTIN OMANDER: I the way you
think because now a business
analyst could draw the
charts in Data Studio
and a developer can focus
on the other pieces of this.
And yeah, no more
building yet another web
app that draws charts.
Somebody has already
done it for us.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Awesome.
This looks so good.
OK, let me just walk through it
real quick, make sure I have it
all.
I think I have enough
for my design doc,
but let's go through it.
OK, so for our web app, we're
going to have App Engine
and we're going to have
Identity Aware Proxy IAP,
to control our
permissions, and we're
going to store all the
requests in Firestore.
And then every
night for our audit,
we are going to have Cloud
Scheduler basically kick off
this pipeline of Pub/Sub and
functions that ultimately
is going to scan
all of our ports,
and we're going to write all
of the results to Pub/Sub,
and we're going to have a
filtered subscription that
sends the bad results
back to App Engine,
we're going to trigger
an email to our admin,
and then we have all of our
results going into BigQuery,
which you are going to show
the reports in Data Studio.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
I really like it.
I think this flow
would work well.
This would actually-- this would
be a fun application to build.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Yeah, I want
to start building this Cloud
Scheduler thing right now.
It looks awesome.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
Yeah, my brain is tingling.
Awesome.
I love these design sessions.
Thank you everyone,
for watching.
This is how you might build
serverless-based systems.
Everything you saw
here was serverless.
If you have any questions
for Dina or me about anything
you saw in this video or
if you have requests for us
for other types of
applications you'd
like to see us do design
sessions for, please add them
in the comments below.
Until next time, bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]